obviously it's got david a bronze medal  so that's that's the good part  go downhill from there wow 19 years ago  and you still remember the game next to  [Music]  you  i mean this could have been some bull  game or i played or something  that's a good guess that's a good guess  i'm probably gonna need a hint  okay it's from uh the entertainment  industry  is okay so  black is down a queen so  from the first harry potter movie they  play the scandinavian and then they went  knight c3 queen c6 so is it from  from that one well done okay  needed some serious hints but it still  could have been anything after the  entertainment industry a good one though